- So, let me know if this
has ever happened to you.
You get really excited
about starting a new diet.
You're starting to feel
like crap about yourself
and you think a new diet
will solve all your problems.
So you start doing some research online.
You read one article about the keto diet
and how it's changing millions of lives.
And then you read another article
about how the paleo diet is the way to go.
And then you keep on
going down the rabbit hole
and you get into veganism and you get into
the carnivore diet which is
completely a 180 from veganism.
Something tells me people
on the carnivore diet
don't hate vegans, but
vegans really hate people
on the carnivore diet.
But anyways, this kind of
situation often happened to me,
but more about starting a business.
Back in university I was
pretty stressed about
making my tuition payments
and I was really frustrated
with my financial situation.
So I would often look online
for best online businesses
to start in 2019.
And I'd read articles
about how drop shipping
will make you millions of dollars.
Then I would watch another video talking
about how drop shipping is
dead and you missed the boat.
So you should start your
own digital marketing agency
or something like that.
The point I'm trying to make is that
we live in the information age.
And this is supposed to mean
that we have an abundance
of knowledge and no
matter what we want to do,
we can learn how to do it.
We can be whatever we want to be
and we can learn how to be that thing,
usually for free, online,
using the internet.
While this is technically true,
we do have this unique problem.
There is so much information out there.
So many people telling you
what the right thing to do is,
that it often contradicts other people.
And it all just becomes a wash.
We're kind of paralyzed by
the amount of information,
not really knowing what path to take.
Being someone who spends so
much time on the internet,
this was especially a problem for me.
But luckily I've adopted a
mindset that really helps me
cut through the crap and
just get on with my life.
I'm finding it's my preferred philosophy
for life in general.
And this philosophy or mindset,
I call the Shoot-First Mentality.
Rather than obsessively deliberating
over what path to take,
just start walking one.
Making bold, uncalculated decisions,
firing from the hip, is often the antidote
to this endless deliberation.
If you make bold, courageous,
decisions at the drop of a hat
and make this your default
mode of solving problems
just trying something,
noticing it doesn't work,
trying again, revising.
Having this action first policy can offer
a plethora of benefits.
Firstly, with an action first mindset
you can get better at things quicker
than people who are
sitting on the sidelines
reading about it.
A great example of this is
when I started this channel.
I had been really thinking
about the proper way
to make a self-improvement channel
and theorizing about
like, whether there was
a opening in the market for
me or if it was too saturated
or how I could make myself stand out.
By the time I made my first video,
none of that really mattered.
Making my first video presented challenges
that I never knew I would have.
And I was able to improve upon
them with every single video.
And I think it's two or
three years later, here I am.
Things are going very well.
And I've learned a lot along the way.
Getting your hands dirty, making mistakes,
trying new things, is by far
the fastest way to learn.
It's way faster than reading about it.
By watching videos about it.
Actually being in the act of doing
the thing that you want
to do and failing at it
will make you get better,
faster than anything else.
The second benefit of adopting
an action first mindset
is that it hardens you.
Or as David Goggins would
say, "It calluses your mind."
And this is all about
getting used to discomfort.
If you train yourself to
battle past the discomfort
of taking immediate, acute action,
then you're able to embrace that feeling.
You're able to push past the
resistance holding you back
from doing what's right,
rather than what's comfortable.
This makes you a very strong
and capable individual.
In times of crisis where
people are losing their heads
because something really
tragic is happening
and something uncomfortable
but necessary needs to be done,
you'll be the kind of
person who can stand there
and do that type of thing
because you're an action taker.
You're not somebody who worries
and stays in their head.
You look for the opportunity
to take the necessary action
and you execute on it.
Ralph Waldo Emerson has this great quote.
"Do the thing and you
will have the power."
It's hilarious quote
because it's so simple,
but it's also a very popular quote
because it's so simply true.
It's really good at describing
the one-to-one relationship
between action and results.
Nothing else will move
anything other than action.
Thinking about it, theorizing
about it, worrying about it,
fantasizing about it.
Nothing changes anything
except taking action.
Do the thing and you will have the power.
Another reason why having
an action first mindset
is superior to a planning first mindset
is because with an action first mindset
you're gonna get burned.
But the lessons you
learned by getting burned
are the ones you remember.
So I have a pretty funny story about this.
We're told our whole life
that gossiping is bad.
Don't talk about other
people behind their backs.
You know, don't talk (beep), basically.
I was also told this my whole life.
The reason why I didn't really register,
I just knew it was bad. Don't do it.
But fast forward to when I was about 16.
There I was at a social outing
and I started going off about how stupid
some lady's outfit was that I saw.
And I kept on going on about it,
just to get attention to myself.
I was hoping to get a
few laughs, ridiculing
this one lady's outfit that
we could all relate to.
And after going on about
it for like, I don't know,
30 whole seconds, I realized that
no one's really laughing at all.
In fact, they look pretty uncomfortable.
And that was because sure enough,
that lady's daughter was one
of the girls I was talking to.
It was one of the most
devastating moments of my life.
My heart completely sank.
I turned into a shell of a human being.
Definitely top three most
embarrassing moments of my life.
And I can guarantee you I
never made that mistake again.
But do I regret it? I don't.
Because I was firing from the hip.
I got burned and I'm a
better person because of it.
Before my last thought, just a quick word
from today's video sponsor, Audible.
So the audio book I'm
currently listening to
is, "Can't Hurt Me", by David Goggins.
And I'm pretty late to the
party with David Goggins.
I actually just discovered
him, but I'm blown away
by the amount of action this guy takes.
This guy is absolutely
crazy, the amount of stuff
he's accomplished, I
don't want to spoil it.
There's actually a really good reason
to get the Audible version, specifically,
because David Goggins
interjects with his own wisdom
and off the cuff thoughts
after the narrator
reads the chapter, it's
actually like a really cool
almost podcasty type of feel.
Would highly recommend it.
Audible has the largest library
of audio books on the entire internet.
With an Audible subscription,
you can download one book
of your choice, absolutely
free, every single month,
along with two Audible originals.
Since Audible is offering
better ideas viewers
a 30 day free trial, that
means you can listen to
"Can't Hurt Me" by David Goggins
right now, absolutely free.
So to sign up for your free trial,
click the link in the description or go
to audible.com/betterideas.
Or text betterideas to 500-500.
The nice thing about Audible is that
if you don't like your audio book
you can easily exchange
it for something else.
And if at any time you
cancel your subscription
you still keep your entire
library of audio books.
So once again, to sign up
for your free 30 day trial
either click the link in the description,
go to audible.com/betterideas,
or text betterideas to 500-500.
Okay guys, I'll leave you with this.
There's a lot of people
who fit into this category;
somebody who chronically
thinks of business ideas.
You have a million dollar
business idea every second week.
You're always thinking of
new things that could blossom
into your financial freedom.
And say, you do this, say you're
thinking of business ideas
for five years and you still
haven't started a business.
Within those five years
you've probably thought of
several, multimillion
dollar business ideas.
You probably have.
But nothing came of it
because you never learned
how to develop a business.
Action taking wasn't your first instinct.
Theorizing and planning
and fantasizing was.
The kinds of people who
develop multi-million dollar
businesses don't have
any more special thoughts
than you do.
They just have special application.
They've been digging in the
trenches, trying and failing,
learning how to start a
business, juggling the logistics
of running one successfully.
Failing a few more times,
and eventually stumbling
into improving their
strategies and getting
to the point where they're
comfortable managing a business.
And when they think of
their million dollar idea,
they know how to apply it.
They just go and do it.
But if you never learned to take action,
your ideas will always
be just that, ideas.
If you liked this video,
make sure to hit like.
Because when you hit the like button
the algorithm does fancy
things and it shoves this video
in front of other people's
faces and my bald head arrives
on people's home pages, and they're like,
"Who's this guy?"
But that's how my channel gets discovered.
And I really would appreciate
it if you hit that like button
so I can help more people out.
And if you're lurking
here and this is like,
the millionth time you've seen my face
and you still haven't hit subscribe,
not only should you hit subscribe,
but you should hit the bell
icon so you can join our
ever-growing notification squad.
I call it a notification
squad, but it's kind of cringy.
You get notifications when I post a video.
And the benefit to that
is when you post a comment
when you're early, I can heart
or respond to the comments.
And as the channel grows, it's harder to
have individual
conversations with every one
of my audience members.
So there's your chance to do it.
Become a part of the
notification conglomerate.
But other than that, yeah,
that's all for today.
Thank you for watching.
And we'll catch you the next video.
(elevator music)